كان فندق Adlon في برلين الذي تم بناؤه عام 1907
واحدًا من أوائل الفنادق الفخمة في أوروبا
التي يرتادها أمثال مارلين
ديتريش تشارلي شابلن والرئيس
روزفلت حتى أن الملكة والأمير
فيليب أقاموا في النادي مرتين
في حالتهم ويمكنك بسهولة معرفة سبب
البحث  بالقرب من
بوابة براندنبورغ وإطلالتها من الجناح
المثالي للصورة ، هناك عدد قليل جدًا من
الفنادق التي تغلق
الوظيفة الإضافية التي كانت خلف الجدار في
برلين الشرقية السابقة ، تاريخ هذا
الفندق ليس في الواقع المادي  المبنى
الذي يزيد عمره عن 20 عامًا بقليل ،
لا يوجد في موقعه
والقصص والأساطير على سبيل المثال في الحرب
العالمية الثانية ، كان فندق Adlon يتمتع
بشعبية كبيرة لدى الدبلوماسيين الدوليين الذين
أقاموا هنا لأنهم شعروا بالأمان
وأصبح معروفًا باسم Little Switzerland
Hitler ولكن لم يحدث أبدًا  أعجبني ad
lon للسبب نفسه الذي وجده دوليًا جدًا